If then you have been raised with Christ, seek the things
that are above where Christ is
seated at the right hand of God,
Set your minds on things that are above,
not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden
with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears,
then you will also appear with him in glory.
Well, good morning again, church.
Now I know what you're thinking,
but no, I'm not officiating a wedding this afternoon.
Uh, this is just something I started a few years ago
as a young pastor out in my first church in Weatherford,
where uh, we spent 26 sermons through the book
of Ephesians, right outta seminary.
And that's just what we thought we needed to do.
And so we all at the end of that, were really tired.
And so I just said we need to honor that in some way
and began this, this little tradition here
and some of you picked up on it.
Thank you for joining me in it.
Uh, but we're excited
because what it means for us today is
that we're closing out this Christ above all series
through the letter to the Colossians.
It's been an amazing study, uh,
through this fall and I've learned so much.
I've been stretched a lot as a preacher through this book.
It's been helpful. My prayer for us is
that it has reawakened us to the glory
of our three in one God, our Lord
and Savior, Jesus Christ, our very life,
our worship, our joy that he is that,
and that it changes us from the
inside out as we come to the end.
What we'll see in the bulk
of chapter four is a beautiful picture of
what we saw back in Colossians one 18, this body
of Christ, the church.
We'll see what it looks like and some ways we can apply it.
And so go ahead now and turn with me
for the final time in this series to the end
of Colossians to chapter four.
I'm gonna start in chapter four, verse seven.
I'm gonna read the whole section first
and we'll dive into what will appear on the surface, kind
of a, a seemingly random list of names.
Hard to preach these sections of scripture actually,
but it's gonna show us a lot.
Colossians four, seven through 18. Look at it with me.
By the way, these names are hard for me to say too.
So just so few you can get there too.
TCUs will tell you about all my activities.
He's a beloved brother, a faithful minister
and fellow servant in the Lord.
I've sent him to you for this very purpose that you may know
how we are, that he may encourage your hearts
and with him, Onesimus, our faithful
and beloved brother who's one of you.
They will tell you of everything that's taken place here.
Aris stares, my fellow prisoner greets you
and mark the cousin of Barnabas
concerning whom you've received instructions.
If he comes to you, welcome him
and Jesus who's called justice.
These are the only men of the circumcision
among my fellow workers for the kingdom of God.
And they've been a comfort to me.
Eris, who's one of you, a servant
of Christ Jesus greets you always struggling on your behalf
in his prayers that you may stand, mature
and fully assured in all the will of God for I ber him.
Witness that he's worked hard for you
and for those in La Deia
and Opolis, Luke, the beloved physician greets you
as does Demas give my greetings to the brothers at La Deia
and to Nimah and the church in her house.
And when this letter has been read
among you have it also read in the church, the Laodiceans
and see that you also read the letter from Laodicea
and say to Archus, see that you fulfill the ministry
that you've received in the Lord.
I Paul write this greeting with my own hand.
Remember, my chains, grace, be with you
Lord, thank you for this word.
We know that this was a personal letter from the Apostle
Paul to this church,
and we're thankful that we get a glimpse into
what you wanted him to say to them so that we could see it
as your word for us today as well.
Lord, it's seemingly random,
but we know that you have a message for each of us today.
So make us good soil.
Give us good ears and eyes to hear
and see what you want us to receive
and bear good fruit through it, Lord, in Jesus' name.
Amen. So the first thing we need to uh,
notice here is the connection of the body.
So I said, this is the body of Christ, the church.
What does the connection look like here?
You'll see it very clearly.
First, you'll see the connection in
that church in in the church there in Colossae within the
church in Colossae itself.
What's the connection look like there?
Well, remember this whole letter has showed this reality of
who they were in Christ together,
that there was a connection
and how they were to behave and that connection.
They were one body in Colossae.
But even here in this section, you see Paul, he
expected them to gather together, most likely in houses
as house churches.
Whether that was one
or multiple, where these letters he was writing to them
or to other churches could be read in that context.
This was not a letter to an individual.
This was a letter to a group of people.
This was to be read together.
So they were connected within the church.
They longed to be together.
You go read acts, you read all of these letters,
you see the longing to be together for them.
It was not an afterthought to gather
with other believers in worship.
They were devoted to the fellowship.
Are you just a simple question in light of that,
the connection within the church, are you devoted
to it like they were?
But you also see further than that there's a connection
of the body of Christ in the region that they're in.
Not just the city of Colossae,
but also in the region surrounding Colossae.
We saw this map at the very beginning of the series
that shows kind of where Colossae is
and La Desia, these names of towns and cities around it.
That's where he mentions La Desia in opis.
Those are two nearby towns on the same trade route.
So they would've been very closely connected to Colossae
where this letter was written to.
And, and most likely the believers in Colossae knew the
believers in Opolis and Le Desia and,
and in fact didn't just know them.
They were so few of them. They needed each other, right?
They were, they were brothers
and sisters in Christ, even from cities
where they were not nearby next door.
And so here's the point of that.
Those Christians in Colossae,
they saw the Christians in Laodicea, in opis, not
as competition,
but as necessary co-laborers in the gospel.
Do we,
it's a piercing question I think for all of us.
Do we see other re churches in our region
As teammates or as rivals in some way?
Here's the reality this morning, probably
'cause of the rain, it's a little bit higher than this, but,
but in Edmond, there is at least 70,000
people who are not going
to church anywhere this morning just in Edmond.
And, and so if that's the reality,
if the Lord could use another church preaching the same
gospel to reach those people that we never could,
then praise God, right?
What if somebody wanted to plant a church in the
YMCA that's coming next door?
We should celebrate that
because they're gonna reach people that we can't.
Like this is regional body of Christ bigger than just us.
It's not the kingdom of Henderson
Hills, it's the kingdom of God.
And so we should see the connection here
and pray for other church.
Let's stop posturing about church size and,
and shuffling a few members here around like, there's plenty
of people out there to fill every church.
That could be what God uses Colossae and Leia
and these others to reach those areas
that they couldn't reach on their own.
Same today.
What you also see in the passage though,
is more than just the region, there's a connection
to the body of Christ in the world, like
around the world.
Not just Colossae, not just the region, but globally.
This goes out from where Paul's writing this
to them in Colossae, most
of the people Paul mentioned in this letter
had never even been to Colossal.
They were not in Colossae for sure had never even been yet.
See the connection Paul makes here.
You had TCUs, one of the couriers of this letter, someone
who the Colossians didn't even know,
but Paul said, here, he's gonna come encourage you.
You had Aris Staris and Mark
and Justice, three of these Jewish background believers
that were with Paul as fellow workers,
but he mentions them as examples of how people like
that even in Colossae could stand fast.
These are Jews following Jesus.
Hey Jews in Colossal, you can too. Here's some examples.
You had Epaphras.
Remember Paul mentioned him back in
chapter one, verse seven.
He's the one who brought the gospel to Colossae
and then he took the news back to Paul
of what had happened there.
So he's not in Colossae anymore,
but he's a connection wherever he
is in the world at this point.
You had the well-known Luke
and Demas who were living somewhere else, we don't know,
but Paul identified them as caring
for the church in Colossae.
They'd never met him before, but, but they cared.
And so why does Paul go through this list
of mentioning all these people in different places?
Well, the Colossian believers needed to know
that they were not alone.
I mean, you get in your little bubble
and you think, I'm the only one.
We're the only ones. We're in trouble here.
So this is surely falling apart. No, they need to know.
There were other believers out there standing with them
That other people outside
of Colossae believed the same things that in Colossae,
they might've been getting mocked for.
They said no, actually,
there's other people believe this too.
We can stand firm.
I mean, just think about how encouraging it is
to you when you hear of God's work and somebody else's life.
Like we're gonna hear at the end of, of the service today,
a baptism testimony of, of that that's meant
to encourage you for how God's worked in his life.
We hear it from other people around the world.
It spurs you on.
But listen, you can do the same thing for people elsewhere.
You can encourage them by your connection
and your response and your letters and your prayers.
It's like what Hebrews 13, three says.
Remember those who are in prison.
That word, remember is not just think about,
it's actually identify with those who are in prison
as though in prison with them
and those who are mistreated since you also
are in the body.
It's the global body of Christ. We're all in this together.
We can encourage others and be connected with them.
And so that's the nature of the body of Christ.
There's a connection here inside and regionally and globally
and eternally that we can have as his body.
We see that here. Yet Paul was not just doing a roll call,
he was also commending the way the body
of Christ should serve in ministry to one another.
Right? So he's listing these names.
Here's some encouragement,
but also he, let's give some examples of what it means
to be the body and serve in ministry to one another.
We see it here now.
You read through the New Testament about 50 times,
you see this phrase one another show up.
And what that means is those are commands given
to the church, to the body of Christ, things
that we ought to imitate today
and how we are to treat one another
and how we are to be together in this body,
the one anothers, we call them how you are
to treat one another.
That means there's a lot more than
what I'm about to say here.
There's 40 plus more,
but I've identified seven here in just this passage alone,
how the body of Christ ministers first
in serving one another.
We should serve one another in the body of Christ.
You see it in verse seven, Paul identified TCUs
as a fellow servant in the Lord.
That word servant means someone who does whatever they can
to make someone feel loved, cared for, helped serving.
Paul gave the example of local boy e Apris.
He worked hard for you.
That's serving archus was to fulfill his ministry.
That's really just a call to serve whatever ministry it was.
But, but I want you to read back through that in your mind.
All the things we saw in this,
the listing and what they were doing.
Notice nowhere in this section do you see
consumer Christianity.
Everyone here in Colossae Le Desia, uh, around the world,
they were focused on giving.
They were focused on counting others
as more significant than themselves to
where they could serve each other.
Listen, if you walk in here every week thinking
what you can get out of this, it's the wrong mentality.
You should come into gatherings like this, looking
for ways you can serve others.
That's when you'll actually receive the benefit out of this.
But, but the focus should be how can I serve the Lord?
How can I serve others in how I come into the gathering
as the body of Christ?
That's the picture we get here of serving one another.
Here's the second one, encouraging one another.
The second one, another here is encouraging.
Now, the same thing Paul wrote back in Colossians two, two,
encouragement was part of what he was working for them
to have because they were discouraged.
He wanted them to be encouraged.
And so he sent TCUs
and animus to help with that encouragement.
But we've gotta ask the question, what is encouragement?
Because we can get a wrong picture in our day
where it's like you just think better about things.
Like you better just change your mind, right?
That's encouraging. Well, actually,
the word here in the original language is the same root word
used back in John 14 to describe the Holy Spirit.
And it says it in a way that he's the helper,
he's the comforter.
And that's the same idea here,
because that's what the Colossians needed, right?
They needed help. They needed comfort.
They didn't just need to change their mind.
They needed help.
And so Paul sent these guys
to comfort them in their affliction,
to help them stand fast.
These worldly philosophies were
coming at them left and right.
They were discouraged
because they felt like it wasn't
working, whatever they were believing.
And so Paul said here, these guys are going to encourage,
going to give you courage to stand in a really dark place.
That's what we need to do for one another as well.
Encourage one another.
Give courage to,
whenever we're discouraged, we need encouragement.
It's not patronizing, it's not generic and niceties.
Hey, you're doing okay, right?
That's not what we're talking about.
We're talking about reminding one another of who God is.
That's what Paul sent these guys to do in Colossae.
Say, Hey, remember who God is. Remember who Christ is.
I'm gonna write a letter that tells all about
Christ above all.
Here he is. Here he is. Remind them. Remind them.
Hey, Colossians, listen. He's God, you can trust him.
You can give your life to him.
Encouragement in that.
So we need to do for each other.
When you're down, you need somebody
to sit across the table from you
and encourage you in who God is.
Next, we see forgiving one another here.
That's the next one, forgiving one another.
Now, where is that in this section?
Well, there's a couple places I believe based on the back
stories that you might not be aware of here.
In fact, you can read it over in Philemon.
There's a really short one page letter called Philemon. It.
It actually talks about this very public tension
that Philemon
and Onesimus here had A public,
uh, issue and problem that they had to deal with.
Yet at this point,
Paul's writing Colossians later it had clearly been resolved
because Onesimus was called faithful
and beloved here, he was free where he once was a slave.
He's free to travel and do the things here.
And Paul was sending him back to the place it happened.
So whatever was going on was resolved.
That only comes through forgiveness,
that it all had been washed away, that they had,
they had reconciled.
There's not only that one, there's also in verse 10,
Paul mentioned Mark, which is the same John Mark
that Paul and Barnabas separated over in Acts 15.
Back in Acts 15, Paul
and Barnabas disagreed over John Mark's
perceived spiritual maturity.
He said, I wanna take him with us.
And he said, no, I don't wanna take him.
And, and so they actually ended up splitting, separating
and going into two different directions from ministry.
But, but they had separated
because of this John Mark, probably in a pretty painful way.
There was a separation there. But look at what happened.
Look, look at what had happened. By now.
Paul now saw Mark as useful to his ministry.
They were back in relationship again.
In fact, a really close one at that where Mark's one
of the three of the former Jews
who actually stayed with Paul.
There was a reconciliation there was for forgiveness.
Now, God can use separations like that
to further his ministry, which he did in that case.
I mean, two separate ministries instead of just one.
Yes, but forgiveness
means reconciliation.
It means glory to God.
It it, it shows us that unforgiveness
only hurts yourself.
It doesn't hurt the other person as much as it hurts you.
And that's not what God calls us to do.
He says, forgive one another as I have forgiven you.
Here's the next one. We see the ministry here of
comforting one another,
comforting one another is here.
It's verse 11, the very end of 11.
You see that they have been a comfort to me.
Paul says, the idea of that word is
that you hurt with someone who hurts.
That's comforting hurt with someone who hurts.
It's consoling someone in their grief, an arm around them,
maybe not even saying anything to comfort them.
It's just your presence with them.
Paul had been abandoned by nearly
everyone else at this point in his life,
but not these three men.
They had been with him, cared for him, loved him.
That was a comfort to his soul.
That is part of the ministry of the body of Christ.
You should be able to be certain if you are a believer in
faith of his life, death and resurrection for you.
If you are a member of the body of Christ,
you should be certain that you are never alone.
'cause one Corinthians 12 says, the members of the body are
to have the same care for one another.
And if one member suffers, all suffer together.
See, we're not just a pile of disconnected body parts.
We are the body of Christ connected, which means we are
to get involved in each other's lives.
Even when it hurts, even when it's hard, we are supposed
to comfort one another
and give comfort and receive comfort as we're known.
You need to be known here.
You can't be known if you're just attending.
You've gotta be known by involvement.
Here's another ministry of the body we see here praying
for one another, praying for one another.
Paul's already prayed a lot
for the Colossians throughout this whole letter,
but look again at verse 12, not just Paul verse 12,
Eris, whose one of you, a servant of Christ Jesus greets you
always struggling on your behalf in his prayers
that you may stand, mature
and fully assured in all the will of God.
Eris had a deep connection.
So much so that he agonized in prayer
for their spiritual growth.
Like how much of a ministry that is, right?
Like we need God to do the work
and so we need to pray that he would do the work, right?
That's not just a generic like, Hey, we're gonna pray.
Uh, just spend some time in prayer.
We're going to go to battle.
We're gonna ask God to work in us and through us
and assure us of his plan for us.
Because that's one thing the Colossians need to be reminded
of, was that it was God's will for them to be saved.
'cause remember, they're, they're struck
by all these other philosophies out there.
And for them to be in this religious melting pot
of colossae, they need to remember that it was God's will
for them to be saved should give 'em confidence.
Same for us. As it gets a little bit harder to declare
to others that you are a follower of Christ, we need
to be reminded and pray for one another, to stand fast
in our faith, fully assured in the will
of God that he called you to salvation.
He saved you. He guaranteed your salvation.
Man, we need to be praying that each one of us can do that
praying for one another.
The next ministry may be a little more hidden here,
but it's just as critical imitate the ministry of
welcoming one another.
Praying for, but also welcoming one another.
Welcome Mark. Verse 10.
He says, yes, but, but this is also in verse 15.
Paul greets MFA and the church in her house.
Now, we don't know much about her.
Most likely she's a, a single wealthy business woman
who was meeting Paul at some point along the way
as she traveled around the region sharing her goods
and services, whatever she had as a business or,
or maybe she was just traveling to purchase more goods.
We don't know. But she met Paul at some point,
heard the gospel, believed it,
and she comes back to Colossae or tole de the region
and notice how she served
by hosting a church in her house.
We don't know exactly what this looked like, but,
but she simply offered what she had.
Most likely it was a big house, lots
and lots of, okay, I'm not gonna go there again.
Right? Uh, but she made it a place
that was welcoming for the church to meet.
She just said, here's my house. We can use it
to meet in because it's big enough.
That's what I hope. You see a lot
of people here in this, this passage.
We're just regular people.
Like we don't know anything about them. They're not famous.
Then you think about the people. He doesn't even mention all
over colossal Leo Decia elsewhere,
that they are just average Joe, average Jane, kind of people
who had been saved by the gospel, believed in Jesus,
and they were collected together
as this regular group of people.
Most of them not playing public roles at all.
They don't even get mentioned anywhere,
but everyone had a part to play.
They were all to serve with what they'd been given,
and that's at least in welcoming one another's.
Romans 15 very explicitly says, welcome one another
as Christ has welcomed you.
So listen, you might never get able to come up here
and teach or to lead music or to do anything that's public
or, or give a lot of money,
and you might not be able to do any of those things,
but you can serve right?
You can find a way to fit. You can welcome one another.
You can be a welcoming face as somebody walks in
that you're not looking like you're disappointed to come
to church today, but you're actually excited to be here.
You can see the joy of the Lord is my strength showing
through your face, even through hard seasons.
That's a welcoming face.
You can show mercy to someone who's sitting alone.
You can hold babies, you can stack chairs.
You can welcome people by hosting them at your house.
You can rake leaves for like on and on.
You can go through all of life
and say, how can I make people feel
loved And cared for?
That's the true spirit of welcoming.
It's not about whether you have folded napkins and
and fitted sheets that are ironed on your beds at home.
Like that's not anything about welcoming.
It's about your spirit.
Do people look at you in the city?
Do they meet you in your neighborhood?
Do they walk in this building
and do they say, man, this,
this feels like it would feel if Jesus was here.
Shouldn't that be the way it is?
Like if Jesus was literally sitting here with us,
how would it feel if he was planning events,
if he was talking with people?
How would it feel? That's the way we should be. Church.
That's being welcoming. That's all of you can do that.
Whether you can preach or lead music or not.
That can be you. Here's the last one.
The final ministry of the body we see mentioned here is in
verse 17 regarding this archus.
The way I'm phrasing this one is calling one another,
calling one another
because looking at it, verse 17, say to Archus, see
that you fulfill the ministry
that you've received in the Lord.
Now, again, we don't know exactly what this ministry was,
but he needed to be reminded that God had called him
to whatever it was,
And Paul used an an interesting say to archivist,
that's a plural form of say so.
He said, Hey, church, call archivist to the ministry
that he knows he has remind him church
that he's got this ministry.
We do that here, don't we?
Nearly weekly, someone right here stands up
and calls you to fulfill the whatever ministry God's given
you, whatever it is, right?
Something unique based on your personality, your story,
your passions, especially your
giftings from the Holy Spirit.
You are called to do it,
and we're reminding you serve, find your place.
Use what you've been given
to fulfill the ministry God has called you to.
But archivist was a leader we think in the church,
and so there's also a distinct call from the Lord to
vocational church roles
that some people within the church do receive, whether
that's to be a pastor or to minister on staff in some way,
or to move overseas as a missionary.
We believe that God calls some to a life
of service, and I believe
he's calling some of you to those tasks.
Again, we're all called to ministry.
Yes, we are, but some
of us are called to make our living by the gospel.
Not all, but some and,
and listen, as I tra trace trends and read blogs
and articles and talk to other pastors,
there is a crisis coming where we will not have enough
vocational ministers to fill the needs in all the churches.
There's not enough pastors coming up, not enough ministers
to fill all these roles
that we have in churches around the country.
There's needs all around the world
where we don't have enough people called to go overseas
or feeling like they should go overseas
and plant their lives somewhere else.
We just don't have enough. There's a crisis coming.
We're not gonna have enough, and I,
I get why it's hard.
The enemy fights hard. You don't get paid very much.
You, you, people can hurt you.
Like I get why people don't do it,
but we desperately need people called into vocational
service for the church.
It's one reason we're kicking off a,
a new residency program very soon
so we can train up more leaders
for the church in the future.
Maybe he's calling you to give your life
and make your living by this gospel message, even
as we are all called to serve.
But listen, it, it doesn't matter how good that program is,
a best residency program.
Mark's doing a great job, but, but he could be the best or
or even how high our percentage of serving is
and we get a hundred percent of people
who attend serve in some way in the church, right?
We could have all of that. It can be the best program.
It doesn't matter if we are not
resting in the power God gives the body
structure, systems, process, whatever, doesn't matter
if we're not resting in the power that God gives the body.
I mean, all this ministry action I've shown here
and really, really the ability to live out the whole
new self kind of life we've seen throughout in Colossians,
like the ability to stand fast against any worldly
philosophy coming your way, the ability
to grow in our worship of Christ.
It all comes from the very last few words
of Colossians, right?
Look at the end of of verse 18, chapter four,
the last four words he writes, grace, be with you,
Amen.
Whose grace, God's grace, right?
So to everything he'd written until this point,
everything he believed, everything
that would empower the Colossians
to live out everything he's just said
for over four chapters, it was summed up in one word, grace,
God's grace, the grace from the Father.
We saw in chapter one verse two,
all the way at the beginning, the grace
of the gospel throughout the whole letter, grace,
that is our power source.
All this that he said, all this that we're doing,
it's worthless apart from the Lord.
It's merely religious behavior modification
and it does nothing for you
and it does nothing for anyone else.
Church. We must not be that kind of people.
We have to see Christ as above all.
We have to see that as we give our very lives to him,
that he will fill us with his spirit, he will make us new.
He will totally transform everything
because he is our source.
He is our very life, and so we open our hands
and we allow him to change us into everything we've seen
here throughout the last few weeks in Colossians.
You can't look at this and say,
all right, I'm gonna do this myself.
I'm gonna make this happen myself. It is.
It's gonna fall flat,
But grace be with you.
That is what God promises
to give you the power to do it.
Grace His
grace and listen.
He's worthy of that. He's worthy of you saying all of life.
God is yours and he will
Empower you To do all that he's said to do here.
Grace, be with you.